donc je passe tout de suite la parole à
eric woerth sur wii sans attendre sur
l'accord concernant la grèce merci
sébastien est un mot sur 7 sur cet
accord
d'abord nous nous félicitons qu'un
accord ait pu être trouvé
sauf sauf rebondissement enfin les
choses ont l'air d'être plutôt en tout
cas en voie de stabilisation
pour nous c'était le seul accord
possible et c'est donc un bon accord
s'il est respecté
toute la question de la mise en oeuvre
aujourd'hui qui comptent les états un
accord qui est conforme à ce que les
républicains souhaitaient plusieurs
membres du parti se sont évidemment
exprimé ces dernières semaines à
plusieurs reprises et toujours dans le
droit fil de ce que nicolas sarkozy a
rappelé hier soir et je voulais leur
dire la grèce on la préfère dans l'euro
que sortie de l'euro donc il fallait
aller jusqu'au bout des négociations
pour que la grèce reste dans dans l'euro
cela étant pas n'importe quel prix pas
n'importe comment pas en se fondant sur
un accord fragile il fallait donc y ait
beaucoup de solidité derrière cet accord
c'est a priori le résultat de cette nuit
et puis évidemment avec en toile de fond
une union franco-allemande très très
solide il ne pouvait pas y avoir
d'accord vont s'en sent que l'union
franco-allemande est à la fois en était
à l'origine
et puis également sans qu' il fallait
évidemment pas que ça puisse briser ou
ou est entaché la l'union de entre nos
deux de deux pays qui sont les moteurs
de l'europe
nicolas sarkozy l'a redit hier soir à
bruxelles avec vigueur il a eu raison
il a appelé d'ailleurs alain juppé
françois fillon bruno le maire ou xavier
bertrand pour en discuter avec eux et je
pense que c'était
bon moment pour le faire et cet accord
aujourd'hui est maintenant sur la table
quels enseignements peut-on tirer de
cette crise qui a duré extrêmement
longtemps
d'abord c'est que les négociations
s'engagent avec les grecs sur la base
des propositions qui avaient été faites
avant le référendum des propositions
très très construite pour engager les
réformes nécessaires à faire en grèce
fait les réformes souhaitable elle avait
pris beaucoup d'engagements sur les
quatre ou cinq dernières années ses
engagements n'avaient pas été tenues
donc d'où la prudence nécessaire et d'où
évidemment les exigences réhaussé des
européens par revenir là dessus je
savais qu'il s'agit de tva qu'il s'agit
de fiscalité vous savez que il s'agit de
retraite bon beaucoup de sujets comme
cela qu'ils sont des sujets qui n'ont
jamais été traitée suffisamment en grèce
et qui doivent l'être
l'idée d'avoir un état suffisamment fort
pour retrouver son autonomie économique
et financière ce qui n'est pas le cas
deuxième enseignement monsieur qui
brasse a fait amende honorable en
donnant les garanties qui attendait les
européens c'était extrêmement important
la confiance avait été brisée avec ce
gouvernement au pouvoir depuis
maintenant près de près de six mois
il fallait absolument que le premier
ministre fasse enfin en tout cas
reviennent sur les propos qu'il avait
tenus jusqu'à présent lève l'ambiguïté
du référendum qui était une ambiguïté
absolument majeur qui avait pris de
court
absolument tous les pays d'europe et
donc le fait qu'on revienne au texte
qu'ils avaient été négociés avant ce
référendum et qu'on améliore ce texte
est l'amélioration c'est plutôt dans la
solidité des garanties le texte est
encore plus solide qu'il ne l'était
avant le référendum était évidemment
tout à fait essentiel troisième
enseignement c'est quand même l'énormité
la taille absolument gigantesque de
l'aide que nous européens allons verser
durant les trois prochaines années
oh
à la grèce c'est plus de 80 milliards
d'euros on verra les chiffres définitifs
lorsque la négociation aura eu lieu
c'est aussi quand on regarde vers le
passé c'est aussi plus de 400 milliards
qui ont été données d'une manière ou
d'une autre à la grèce à la fois en plan
daide à la fois aussi en réaménagement
restructuration renégociation delà de la
dette à un moment donné et si on ajoute
les fonds structurels
on dépasse évidemment tout cela donc
tout ce qui indique que la grèce n'a pas
été suffisamment aidé que la grèce est
une victime et que les européens sont au
fond des d'horrible et de et de vilains
créanciers tout cela se trompent
puissamment sur la lecture qu'on doit
donner à cela pour que l'art est la
grèce reste en zone euro évidemment pour
qu'elle reste en europe ça c'était ça
allait de soi mais pour que elle reste
dans la zone euro les moyens comme les
efforts ont été jusqu'à présent
considérable dans les années 2010 11 12
et puis maintenant en cette année 2015
donc les sept partis de l'aide ce
troisième plan ne pouvaient être mises
en oeuvre qu'avec un accord extrêmement
solide donc tout dépendra de sa mise en
oeuvre et je pense que les négociations
qui vont s'ouvrir puisque c'est un
mandat de négociation qui s'ouvre que
ces négociations jour on est ce qui
prend beaucoup de de la solidité de
cette mise en oeuvre 3e ou 4e je ne sais
pas enseignement c'est que s'ils paradis
c'était la sortie de l'euro ben
maintenant on sait que ce n'est pas le
cas moi je renvoie la balle aux à des
partis politiques français si on fait un
peu de politique française un instant le
front national qui a encore redit ce
matin que au fond de paradis c'était de
sortir de l'euro on voit bien que
monsieur de seabra ce qui est un leader
d'extrême gauche et donc qu'ils avaient
était plutôt dans cette dans cette voie
là il ya quelques quelques quelques
années même si il n'avait pas dit
lorsqu'il a été candidat
on voit bien que monsieur tibre à se
confronter à la réalité de l'économie
confrontée aux réalités du pays et de
son pays confronté
on fait de savoir si un pays doit rester
isolé ou au contraire partager la même
monnaie
il n'a pas hésité il n'a pas hésité il
est allé jusqu'au référendum pour tenter
dans le cadre de la politique interne
grec de se re légitimer et puis on voit
bien que derrière les mesures qui ont
été choisis par les démocraties
européennes sont les mesures qui vont
être prises et que si monsieur dick
brass accepte de l'essayer c'est
qu'évidemment c'est aussi l'intérêt de
la grèce et que l'intérêt de la grèce
comme l'intérêt des autres pays
c'est évidemment de partager une monnaie
une monnaie commune donc si le paradis
c'était la sortie de l'euro je le redis
aujourd'hui
on voit bien que ce n'est pas le cas
c'est une une preuve en direct de la
stupidité des propositions du front
national sur ce sujet s'est aussi d'une
certaine façon quand même de mettre en
contrepoint les propos extrêmement
violents qui ont été tenus à l'égard de
l'allemagne par monsieur mélenchon et
quelques autres où monsieur
dupont-aignan
c'est pas comme ça qu'on construit
l'europe et c'est pas en rappelant
systématiquement l'europe à son aile son
passé terrible on la construit ces
violences verbales était évidemment
inapproprié et puis dernier
dernier enseignement c'est que s'il faut
accélérer les réformes en grèce pour
faire en sorte que la grèce redevienne
un pays à part entière de la zone euro
c'est-à-dire autonome si nous sommes
prêtes les aider nous touche les 18
autres pays
il faut évidemment en même temps et
probablement au même rythme
réorganiser la zone euro elle même
nicolas sarkozy l'a dit il ya plusieurs
semaines et l'a redit la zone euro
aujourd'hui à montrer au fond un piètre
visage
négociation extraordinairement
laborieuse sûr je le rappelle 2% de son
de son pipe même si la grèce est un pays
important et aucun pays ne l'est pas
enfin quand même temps deux mois à
tergiverser n'est pas vraiment à mettre
à l'actif des européens on voit bien à
ce moment-là que vraie question c'est la
gouvernance de la zone euro
il faut aller plus loin dans cette
gouvernance il faut profiter de cette
crise comme toujours pour en faire une
chance pour la zone euro aller vers plus
d'intégration économique vers plus de
convergence fiscale vers la création
d'outils plus puissant le président des
républicains a appelé de ses voeux la
création d'un fonds monétaire européen
en remplacement du mécanisme européen de
stabilité
enfin bref que la zone euro soit
aujourd'hui à la hauteur des attentes
qui sont en elles et qui avait été celle
initiale au moment de la création de la
zone euro
on voit bien aujourd'hui que le moment
est venu donc on accélère sur la grèce
on consolide et en même temps en
accélère et on consolide la zone euro
voilà ce que je peux peut-être vous dire
ce lundi matin
d'accord annoncés entre tous les pays
entre tous les pays d'europe sur cette
crise grecque je suis prête à répondre à
vos questions si vous le souhaitez
bonjour qu'est ce que vous répondez au
gouvernement qui a dénoncé l'ingérence
de nicolas sarkozy en par ses prises de
position hier pendant les négociations
ni enfin j'ai entendu nicolas sarkozy
bien se voir comme comme comme nous tous
il est humilié fois raison de tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé mille fois raison et
c'est le rôle d'un d'un grand leader de
l'opposition à sarkozy il est certes
ancien président mais enfin il est
surtout dans la politique active il est
président des républicains
il a eu mille fois raison de dire ce
qu'il pensait et qui résumait ce qui
avait été dit par la plupart d'entre
nous depuis de nombreuses semaines avec
des variations dans dans la manière de
dire mais assez assez peu je vois un
petit show est assez peu je suis prête à
répondre et il a eu bien raison qu'est
ce qu'il a dit il est dit qu'il fallait
qu'il ya un compromis un accord qui soit
qu'ils soient signés
il est toujours là toujours été sur sept
sur sept sur sept phases et sur 7 sur
cette piste et d'autres je l'avais dit
également on n'a pas voulu fermer la
porte
là le référendum a sonné un peu
bizarrement dans le ciel
européen vous pouvez l'interpréter comme
le fait que les grecs avaient décider in
fine et de dire non à l'europe
nous avons au contraire pris position
pour dire tant qu'un accord est possible
allons-y le pire c'est quand même la
sortie de la grèce de l'euro parce que
c'est tout à fait tout à fait
incalculables comme conséquence c'est
probablement d'ailleurs assez assez
coûteux nicolas sarkozy a eu raison hier
de dire il faut qu'ils aient un
compromis qui soit signé je vous
rappelle qu'il reçoit c'était pas tout à
fait l'ambiance est donc il ya donc à
tout moment on peut intervenir parce que
comme une ambiance extraordinairement
volatile pour parler en termes de marché
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il
fallait le faire deuxième point que ce
compromis ou cet accord je préfère
d'ailleurs le terme d'accords que cet
accord il ne pouvait être solide que
s'il était porté clairement et pas de
manière ambiguë par la france et par
l'allemagne
on voit bien que c'est la france et
l'allemagne qui détiennent la clé est
que si la clé n'est pas tout à fait la
même
on a peu de chances d'ouvrir la serrure
et c'est une raison de le dire parce que
hier soir on avait un peu le sentiment
et pendant toute la journée d'hier et
celle d'avancer qu'il y avait d'un côté
l'idée qu' il fallait quand même
négocier avec les grecs et de l'autre
les allemands qui faisait monter les
enchères
la vérité c'est qu'il fallait bien faire
en sorte que ce qui était demandé aux
grecs soient suffisamment suffisamment
sérieux pour que le plan 80 milliards
puissent être votées dans des conditions
de garantie de garanties suffisantes et
les allemands ont eu raison de faire
monter la pression et on avait le
sentiment que le président français
était plutôt hésitants là dessus je vous
rappelle que c'était oui à la grèce dans
l'euro mais pas n'importe quelle
condition pas n'importe quelle condition
pas n'importe quel prix parce que si le
prix est faible aujourd'hui
alors il sera très fort demain et c'est
que si l'accord doit être soutenable ou
durable alors il doit être pris dans des
conditions où aucune ambiguïté subsiste
il ya eu beaucoup d'ambiguïté sur toutes
ces années avec la grèce donc aucune
ambiguïté ne doit subsister et
l'attitude de monsieur cipra sur ces
dernières semaines ou 6h05 dernier - le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
c'était une attitude qui a rompu
puissamment la confiance dans la
capacité de la grèce à s'engager
durablement vis-à-vis des européens pour
obtenir un plan dette supplémentaire
donc nicolas sarkozy il a eu il a eu
bien raison
hier et c'était son rôle il est
président des républicains c'est pas une
la statue du commandeur c'est pas du
tout quelqu'un qui a été ancien
président de la république et qui donne
un coup s'exprime du hot son aventin
c'est quelqu'un qui est dans la
politique active des présidents des
républicains il a résumé cette île a
résumé ce que nous en pensons sur hier
soir il a eu je les dis la plupart des
leaders de notre de notre parti
politique au téléphone dans la soirée
bien fictions de radio france
internationale excuse moi tu cherches
une radio france internationale pour
poursuivre la question de mon collègue
est ce que quand même la déclaration de
nicolas sarkozy qui appelle françois
hollande à se ressaisir samedi est ce
qu'elle est un petit peu en décalage
aujourd'hui quand on voit qu'il ya un
compromis aujourd'hui c'est à dire plus
tout est ma deuxième ma deuxième
question est ce que vous considérez que
c'est une victoire c'était pas en
décalage parce que françois hollande
s'est ressaisi tant mieux heureusement
il s'est ressaisi et on peut pas avoir
de position louvoyante où je pense qu'
il fallait éviter toute idée d'une forme
de complaisance vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis
des grecs
il faut comprendre il fallait agir il
fallait être en partenariat avec les
grecs mais surtout en partenariat avec
les 18 autres pays notamment avec les
éléments et et les déclarations de
wolfgang schauble
les déclarations de la chancelière était
tout à fait importante et la france
n'avait pas à s'aligner sur
systématiquement sur la position
allemande
mais il avait à discuter d'une position
commune cette position commune ça ne
pouvait être que sur la base de
propositions
jeu solide et dur c'est des propositions
qui sont durs pour le pays à court terme
et qui n'ont à mon avis assure le
l'avenir de ce pays à moyen terme et
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire et le
président sarkozy a eu bien raison de le
faire
j'en sais rien enfin c'est à c'est un
accord en tout cas c'est un c'est un
accord s'il est respecté qui est un qui
est un bon accord donc il faut le on en
a le plaisir de le dire ma participer au
fonds en tant que formation de
l'opposition également à donner donner
aussi l'ambiance autour de cette de cet
accord est ce que je pense c'est une
victoire de de l'europe jeu des dix neuf
des 18 plus sain et puis françois
hollande a joué sont les 6 et consacré
avec beaucoup d'énergie
j'aimerais bien maintenant qui se
consacre avec la même énergie à la
réforme de l'état français qui parfois
on n'a presque pas autant besoin que
l'état grec mais il ya certaines
réformes qui sont imposées aux grecs
nous devrions nous imposer à nous mêmes
sommes si les négociations avaient
échoué ça aurait été la faute de
françois hollande mais maintenant qu'ils
ont réussi
il comprend pas cette question
ça a été c'est une négociation
compliquée probablement laborieuse
le président le président à l'entrée
dans cette affaire depuis fin il s'est
notamment impliqué du tout depuis cinq
ou six mois j'ai six étaient impliqués
depuis cinq ou six mois alors il y
aurait probablement la volonté aurait
été de dire quoi je ne dis pas ça arrive
au pouvoir
il passe son temps sur la grèce sur le
sur la dette pardon de la grèce et pas
sur les réformes à mener
peut-être qu'un président français un
peu active il lui aurait dit j'adore la
grèce j'ai très envie que tu restes dans
la zone euro mais il faudrait peut-être
que tu fasses les réformes nécessaires
tout ça n'a pas eu lieu
mais pour le président hollande est
monté tardivement au créneau en essayant
de s'inventer un rôle de négociateur
entre les allemands les grecs c'est ça
qu'on a dénoncé il peut pas y avoir de
négociateur entre les allemands et les
grecs y avait d'un côté des européens
convaincus qu'il fallait que la grèce
reste dans l'euro semble-t-il la seule
position cède et c'est pour ça que ça a
fonctionné c'est parce que tout d'un
coup on est revenue sur cette position
scène qui était absolument nécessaire et
on voit bien que l'accord franco
allemand qui a dû être décidée à un
moment donné dans la soirée dans la nuit
je ne sais pas
la petite histoire le dira mais que au
fond qui est plus l'épaisseur d'une
feuille de papier à cigarette je
l'espère entre la position française est
la position allemande ont fait en sorte
que les grecs ont accepté cette position
et c'est ça que nous souhaitions pas on
est ravis on est heureux on comprend pas
bien pardon ce qui vous permet de dire
que françois hollande s'est ressaisie
hier je comprends pas bien ce qui a
changé dans sa position à lui et
deuxième question est ce que l'issue des
négociations selon vous donne aussi tort
à ceux qui dans votre famille politique
notamment alain juppé pour ne pas le
nommer considéré qu'une sortie de la
grèce de la zone euro et est inéluctable
et qui fait donc l'accompagner
écoutez moi je pense qu'elle a juppé il
a dit ce qu'il avait à dire le lendemain
du référendum et le lendemain du
référendum
on pouvait absolument interprété la
réponse du peuple grec comme un nom à la
zone euro la question était tellement
ambigu tellement pas clair est
d'ailleurs tellement pas clair dans la
tête de monsieur type race aussi
fondamentalement puisqu'il a décidé de
faire le contraire trois jours après
donc voilà franchement j'étais quand
même le moins qu'on puisse dire un
référendum utilisé de manière un peu
bizarre tout le monde l'interprète comme
il veut c'est extraordinaire et
aujourd'hui le peuple grec qui a dit non
à 60% à ceux à ce plan accepte non pas
par référendum un monsieur qui passe à
faire un homme enfin je n'ai pas entendu
parler donc accepte ce référendum
accepte le contenu du référendum et
accepte même affaire d'hommes plus
puisqu'il ya des mesures supplémentaires
notamment le fonds de garantie donc
c'est une est une bonne chose
quant au fait de ceux de se ressaisir je
ne sais pas je sais pas si c'est régis
en tout cas tout ce que je remarque
c'est que le couple franco allemand il a
recommencé à fonctionner ne fonctionnait
plus il ne fonctionnait plus donc il a
recommencé à fonctionner et tout ce qui
est ambigu tous qui louvoie tout ce qui
donne le sentiment de jouer double jeu
est quelque chose qui est affaibli
l'europe et c'est ce que nous avons
dénoncé et nous avons raison de le
dénoncer sommes une formation
d'opposition et on assume parfaitement
sa
non vous qu'on va jamais parce que vous
avez des idées préconçues en tête
comment vous expliquer le changement de
position de nicolas sarkozy sur la grèce
puisqu'il ya dix jours dans les colonnes
du monde
il décrète la sortie de la grèce de la
zone euro il dit la grèce est suspendue
elle même de la zone euro mercredi soir
dernier sur tf1 il nous dit je souhaite
un compromis à tout prix comment est ce
qu'on peut comprendre mais enfin je jeu
méthode de chez de ces questions nicolas
sarkozy n'a pas varié un instant sur la
grèce il n'a jamais varié sur l île a
indiqué dans une interview avant le
référendum ce que la plupart d'ailleurs
nous disions c'est que ce référendum il
portait sur la présence de la grèce dans
l'euro ou pas c'était au fond comme ça
qu'il fallait interpréter et c'était
bien naturel avant le référendum de
mettre la pression pour bien expliquer
au peuple grec parce que il y avait que
la parole de monsieur tsipras ce qu'il
disait non et je vers l'intérêt de la
grèce
très franchement l'intérêt de la grèce
n'ont visiblement c'est ce que monsieur
type race accepte aujourd'hui donc
l'intérêt de la grèce était bien de
rester dans la zone euro et la question
qui a été posée à ce moment là par
monsieur qui brassent était
extraordinairement ambigu très ambigu et
nicolas sarkozy a eu raison comme
d'autres de dire qu' il y avait là un
risque majeur est d'ailleurs ce risque
il a failli se réaliser dire qu'après le
référendum
enfin on n'est pas là on avait une
semaine qu'on en parle après référendum
cts qu'elle reste est ce que le gars
exit va avoir lieu ou pas où il va avoir
lieu non il va pas avoir lieu donc tout
ça était très instable pas du tout
stabiliser
donc nicolas sarkozy tire une première
sonnette d'alarmé avant le référendum
pour dire attention il ya un risque de
grésil
on n'en veut pas on n'en veut pas mais
un risque majeur c'était la réponse au
référendum
le référendum a lieu puis plus personne
n'y comprend rien getti prince dit au
fond je veux pas que la grèce sorte de
la zone euro et il se met à accepter dès
le mercredi les propositions qui était
dans le référendum dimanche et qui avait
été refusée dimanche par son propre
peuple comprenne quand même et il faut
être souple info les chine un peu souple
il comprend qu'au fond l'avenir de son
pays il il est dans la zone euro et pas
ailleurs
et tout d'un coup je pense qu'ils s'en
aperçoivent façon extraordinairement
forte et il ne pense pas que les
européens peuvent aller aussi loin de le
sortir de la zone euro puis tout d'un
coup il s'aperçoit que si qu'il est
qu'il est à un pas du précipice et il
fait marche arrière
il se met à accepter ce qui est ce qui
se passe et puis cette période un peu
ambigu entre d'un côté des éléments qui
essayait de le dire alors il faut
consolider les choses parce que la
rupture de la confiance est très forte
et puis de l'autre le président français
qui dit ouais j'ai c'est d'être un trait
d'union parce que parce que c'est bien
d'être un trait d'union
ça c'est tous les deux derniers jours et
puis hier soir et dans la nuit
l'idée que le couple franco allemand il
doit se ressaisir lui aussi il doit se
reconstituer on doit probablement les
allemands doivent probablement lâcher un
peu de lest pas beaucoup mais ils n'ont
pas beaucoup la chair mais lâcher un peu
de lest
mais que ce soit très solide très
sérieux puis dire à monsieur de sipera
ce en échange de cela il ya un plan tout
à fait gigantesque dead
je pense que chacun a joué son rôle est
plutôt bien
bien la caravane d'été
nous passons au traditionnel agenda donc
demain mardi 14 juillet à partir de 14
heures lydia guirous c'est roger
karoutchi sont ici au siège pour faire
les réactions à l'intervention télévisée
du 14 juillet de françois hollande
d'ailleurs on nous indique que françois
hollande voudrait se poser en président
de combat nous craignons que françois
hollande se pose en président des
combinaisons puisque on s'attend à ce
qu'il y en ait pour tout le monde dans
sa majorité un petit peu pour son centre
gauche un petit peu pour les frondeurs
un petit peu pour la gauche de la gauche
pour un petit peu pour l'extrême gauche
enfin voilà les combinaisons dans le
cadre des grandes manoeuvres pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 seront
à l'honneur à l'occasion de cette
intervention du 14 juillet mercredi 15
juillet à 18h15 auront lieu la
commission nationale d'investiture
dimanche 19 juillet nicolas sarkozy sera
dans les alpes-maritimes à nice pour le
lancement de la caravane d'été des
jeunes républicains
il sent on ira dans la soirée pour la
tunisie puisqu'il sera en déplacement du
19 au 21 juillet en tunisie où il
rencontrera le président et un certain
nombre de hauts responsables tunisiens
il lors de cet
de ce déplacement donc le 20 juillet il
visitera le musée du bardo et dans la
foulée aura un moment de recueillement à
la mémoire des victimes de l'attentât
qui ont lieu qui a eu lieu dans ce musée
le lundi soir il tiendra un meeting
commun avec le parti ni d'atouts nes qui
est donc le parti du président en
exercice tunisien et nous retrouverons
donc lundi 20 juillet pour le point
presse hebdomadaire
je voulais vous préciser que nicolas
sarkozy avec les difficultés des
agriculteurs a eu exactement là où
téléphone et ils ont convenu qu'il y
aurait à la rentrée une journée de
travail avec la fnsea pour faire un
certain nombre de propositions fortes
pour l'agriculture française
on va passer au sujet des élections
jeunes mardi le bureau des des jeunes
s'est réuni dans le cadre des nouveaux
statuts qui garantit l'indépendance
politique aux jeunes républicains mais
dans le cadre du respect des valeurs du
centre et de la droite républicaine de
nouvelles élections auront lieu
une liste d'union menée par marine
brunier qui est responsable des jeunes
des alpes-maritimes et je crois qu'elle
varie noki responsable des jeunes de
seine-saint-denis va réunir plusieurs
jeunes de différentes tendances
si on peut alors nicolas sarkozy a posé
quatre conditions pour pour pour cette
liste des jeunes donc il faut un respect
de la parité un respect du
renouvellement nous voulons qu'il y ait
de nouveaux jeunes qui qui émerge à
travers cette élection
il veut également s'appuyer sur les
responsables au niveau de l'ensemble des
territoires donc plutôt des responsables
départementaux donc des rdj et puis
aller vers que ses responsables aille
vers des jeunes de différentes
sensibilités afin d'avoir véritablement
un renouvellement et un élargissement de
cette liste pour pour réunir l'ensemble
des républicains donc sous en respectant
ces conditions le président apporte un
soutien à cette liste de rassemblement
l'élection aura lieu le 9 et 10
septembre par voie électronique et pour
le moment c'est une liste qui rassemble
huit personnes et qui aura vocation à en
rassembler 20 voilà évidemment pour en
ce qui concerne les contrôles la haute
autorité sera là pour pour contrôler
l'ensemble de de ce scrutin
alors la caravane la caravane des jeunes
débutent le 19 juillet je vais je vais
convoquer sacha pour pour la présenter
alors je vais parler d'un sujet un peu
plus léger après tout ça donc la
caravane des jeunes le bureau national
sortant des jeunes qui est donc pas le
bureau qui se présentent mais le bureau
qui a été mis en place il ya quelques
années a organisé une caravane des
jeunes qui partira donc vous avez le
petit flyer qui partira le 19 juillet de
nice en présence de nicolas sarkozy et
de christian estrosi et qui arrivera
symboliquement le 23 août au touquet
c'est une arrivée symbolique quelques
semaines avant en fait le campus qui se
tiendra au touquet le deuxième week-end
de septembre donc en fait cette caravane
will 11 septembre merci et donc
doucement
donc en fait ce cette caravane a deux
objectifs 1 relancer le mouvement des
jeunes
en parallèle de ces élections puisque
vous savez que le mouvement des jeunes a
eu quelques petits soucis ces derniers
mois et deuxièmement c'est aussi
redonner la parole aux jeunes puisque
c'était le premier engagement de
françois hollande c'est aussi son plus
grand échec
on peut dire ça comme ça et donc à
travers l'application directe citoyens
qui nous permet de le faire
nous consulterons tout l'été les jeunes
sur différents thèmes
c'est une sorte en fait d' états
généraux de la jeunesse qui permettra à
la nouvelle équipe qui sera élu au
campus du touquet d'avoir un espèce de
cahier des charges très claire de la
mission que lui confient nos
sympathisants et nos jeunes militants
voilà